-Our first guest tonight
is a talented actor and host
you know from his work on shows
like "Brooklyn Nine Nine"
and "America's Got Talent".
His new memoir, "Tough:
My Journey to True Power,"
is out Tuesday.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend, Terry Crews,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
-So nice to have you back,
in the studio, no less!
-Real people!
-Real people.
-Real people. I love real
people. I love you!
-They are very nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And real peope love you.
We missed you.
We had a "Brooklyn Nine Nine"
finale show.
You had obviously
filmed the finale
months before we did this,
but we had
the gang back together.
You weren't here,
but we went out of our way
to make sure
you were represented.
And were you happy
with the cardboard cutout
we used for you?
-I saw it. I loved it.
The pecs popped really
wonderful.
-You can see
that there's no technology.
This is not CGI.
-This is all real.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is it!
-But we got the finest
the finest technicians on Earth
to see if they could replicate
this on a cardboard cutout.
Let's take a look.
We do have a cutout Terry,
and we're very happy with
the technology that we've used
to make his pecs go.
-Ooh!
-Yeah, it's really good.
Really good.
-Yeah.
-You know, the thing is, every
year it gets better and better,
because they kind of
droop a little more.
-Right.
Oh, that's interesting.
-In a minute, I'm gonna
hit myself in the face.
It's gonna be like,
oh, oh, oh.
-The best thing is,
every single one
of your cast mates said, "I want
it, I want it, I want it."
And then they just
left it in the hallway
and we had to get rid of it,
because every time
I walked to my dressing room,
I'd turn on the lights
and it would scare
the [bleep] out of me.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-You know, I have a statue
of myself in my house.
-Who doesn't?
-I know!
Who doesn't have a statue?
And my wife would go in and it
would scare her every morning.
She was like, "You've got to
get this sucker out of here."
-How long have you had
a statue of yourself?
-It was for fittings
and stuff like that,
for the show.
So I was out
and they would fit the thing,
and then I fell in love
with it and I kept it.
[ Laughing ]
-So it sounds like a mannequin
that you're calling a statue.
-Well.
-Okay.
So was it hard?
You know, I can only imagine
what it was like
the last day of shooting
on a show like that
that had such a wonderful cast.
You all seemed genuinely close.
-I still get emotional
about this, because, for one,
you know, I spent more time
with that cast
than I did my own family.
And, you know...
-But your family got to be
with the statue.
It wasn't like they had no one.
-Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It was raising my kids.
But, you know,
but we got the chance
to end it the way we wanted.
I mean, it's totally bittersweet
because it was so sad.
But at the same time, like,
we got an ending.
There's so many shows that just
cut off and it's a wrap.
And I think we ended it
the perfect way.
It was perfect.
-Well, congratulations.
It was a really lovely one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So this is your second memoir.
-Yes.
-I can imagine
early in your career,
you might not have thought you
would have one memoir in you,
and now you've got two.
-Well, first of all,
when I did my first one in 2014,
it was called "Manhood".
And I was like, "This is it.
This is the one.
And then more life happened
and more questions happened
and people kept, you know --
The first thing I brought up
in that first book
was toxic masculinity.
And people were like,
"What is that?"
And then the Academy Awards
happened,
and you start to understand,
and you start
to see all these examples.
And I got more and more
questions, and I said,
"It's time for another book,"
because I wasn't
always the nice guy
you see in front of you
right now, Seth.
There were times that
I had extreme rage,
and it was so wild,
because there had been
a lot of people who've been
knocked out by me before.
And what was so nuts is
that my wife was literally like,
"Hey, you got to promise me
that you will never react
in violence, ever again."
And I was like, "Oh, come on.
I got to do this. I'm a man."
And she's like, "No. No."
And the time that I didn't,
it actually saved my life,
which was so incredible.
-That's
an amazing thing to hear.
And I can only imagine how
easy it was to fall into that.
Obviously, you had a
professional football career
before you
found your way into acting.
That's, you know,
an inherently violent sport.
I've heard you say
you did you did not have
an ego to match your skills.
Can you explain exactly...?
-Well, I wasn't that good
a football player.
-Yeah.
-Okay, let's just...
-You must've been good
at level...
When did you realize
it was above your, like --
Was it the pros
where you were like --
-No, I went all the way.
You got to understand,
you can go a long way in the NFL
with a bad parent
and lots of rage.
It'll get you really far,
because you take a lot of pain.
-That's not in
any of the commercials.
-No, it's not. It's not.
But you will.
You'll go, because it's
one of those things where
they need someone who --
First of all,
I also needed approval,
so coaches and different things,
and that was my way
to get approval from people,
in playing ball
and all this stuff.
But one thing I realized is that
I actually did not like
football at all.
-Did you have a lights on moment
when that happened for you?
-Yes, I was trying out
for the 49ers.
It was my -- like, I was
on six teams in seven years.
So the seventh team
I was trying out for,
the coach threw the ball at me
and it dislocated my finger.
My finger was sitting there
like a L and I was like,
"I don't like this anymore.
Why am I playing?
I don't like it."
And you know what I realized?
This was the thing that hit me.
I realized I just liked playing
outside all day with my friends.
That was it.
And once I started to do that
and substitute it
with all this stuff,
I was like, "I was getting hit
all these years,
and I didn't need to do that."
I was like, "Man, we could
just go play badminton."
-Yeah.
-And it was all good.
I had the breakthrough you had
as a Pop Warner football player.
-I remember.
-[ Laughing ]
-Yeah, I remember I was
on a Pop Warner football team
and we were in,
like, the state finals.
And if we won,
we'd go to regionals,
and I was sitting on the bench,
where I spent a lot of my time,
and our team fumbled
and we lost.
And I realized I hated football,
'cause I was so happy.
Like, our whole team was
upset on the bus.
And I was like,
"Oh, I think I hate this."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, this was --
I know you're also an artist.
We've talked about this
on the show.
You wrote and illustrated
one of my kid's favorite books,
and you used to do
portraits of players.
So this was during your
playing days?
-That's right.
-And you would sort of
supplement your income
with this?
-What I used to do is,
because I got cut a lot, okay?
So I would go back
in the locker rooms
and ask the players if they
wanted their portraits painted,
because they had just
as big an ego as I did.
I was like, "Yo, I'm going
to make you look so amazing.
You're going to look great."
"Yeah, man. I want that, man.
Yeah, boy."
And I would get money
for these paintings
and I would do like,
three or four paintings
in the offseason, get like
three or four grand apiece,
and it would help me
survive with my family
and get me to the next team.
Because I was in art.
I had an art scholarship before
I had a football scholarship.
But now it's so good
to actually be
and live this artistic life.
This is what
I always wanted, you know?
-Well, it's nice,
and now, of course,
you're on a show
that is surrounded by talent
and all different talents.
And when Simon Cowell was here,
I asked him, you know,
do people on the street,
do people in public
ever go up to you and just
start doing their talent
in hopes that they'll get like
a little, free judgment?
-[ Sighs ]
-That ever happen for you?
-Yes.
First of all, I was on a plane
and the pilot comes out.
He's like, "I love
'America's Got Talent'!
And, you know, first of all,
there's a bug and a rat
and they go into a bar --"
And you're like, "Oh, man.
He's doing his steal!"
He's a stand-up comedian pilot!
And I was like, "But who's
flying the plane, man?"
I was like, "But that's funny."
And, you know, I'm like,
"Ha ha ha, let's fly the plane."
And it's going. It's in the air.
-Yeah.
-And he's just doing his spiel
and you've got to laugh.
It's a captive audience.
-Yeah, 'cause then you're
like, of the two pilots,
you want at least
one of their main talents
to be flying a plane, you know?
-Exactly.
-Hey, congratulations
on the book.
-Oh.
-It's always a delight
to see you.
Terry Crews, everybody!